peu plus
vous connaissez tous la patrouille de
france
cette magnifique escadrille capable des
plus folles acrobaties à des vitesses
supersoniques hommes qui le 14 juillet
pour la joie des grands et des petits
un prime dans le ciel notre vos drapeaux
français
[Applaudissements]
mais savez vous comment on devient de
ces as de l'aviation qui font partie des
meilleurs pilotes du monde en tenue que
tous nos gars au départ sont triés sur
le volet c'est relativement deux ans
donc à mon compte et deux ans pour
qu'une jeune recrue soit membre de la
patrouille de france oui s'il ne craque
pas bien sûr vous avez beaucoup
d'abandons son côté la % environ mais
l'entraînement est très dur disons qu'il
est soutenu et rigoureux c'est un
entraînement que j'ai mis au point avec
le général d'at rôle il ya sept ans et
qui donne de très bons résultats et en
quoi consiste-t-il mon colonel nos gars
s'entraînent sans avion
[Musique]
tour de contrôle dont de contrôle à
charlie bravo roger piqué du nez et
comment ces formations vraie question
quand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
i know charlie bravo roger le prenez pas
de risques sur votre droit
préparez vous atterri en formation
déployés
il
[Musique]
vous
papa
faudra faire des pompes alex s'émousse
un jour tu veux finir par avoir un pépin
au décollage
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'ère pierre
coupe les gaz
pour gauche qui libre je veux pas que tu
voles avec sa maman colonel ma dentiste
c'est tout bien emballé les gars bonjour
les gars je peux vous poser une question
on s'habitue vite à ce genre de vie rue
même au départ c'est un petit peu
impressionnant quand même avouer la
première fois qu'on y va en cours dans
le pré convoi l'air défilé à toute
allure sous les pieds ça habitants
dépensent plus tôt
heureusement moi c'est ça oui au début
ce qu'il ya de plus impressionnant
surtout c'est le rase mottes
bon appétit les gars tu trouves tu
entends rouge
j'avais prévu
au bout de deux ans on fin de stage
quand nos petits gars sont bien prêts
nous les préparons pour le 14 juillet
c'est l'exercice auquel vous avez
assisté
je vous en prie
facile
[Musique]
très impressionnant
ah non alpha tango et 6 tours de
contrôle alpha tango quelque chose qui
cloche
répondez et ses six enfants tango je
crois que jacques gaillot de la
chaussure je vais soutenir au maximum
d'aller décrocher alpha tango inutile
d'insister alpha tango
quitte à ce crétin d'atterrir
immédiatement mais mon colonel alpha
tango atterrissait c'est un ordre
ce
ce qui l'attend ce fou
fargo répondait afin tango répondait
répondeur iff attendons ici tour de
contrôle répondait à ses lois faton go à
satan goût
aucun modèle basé sur le coupé sa tombe
il
et se passe-t-il
je vais vous demande est repoussé
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça aussi la patrouille de france
[Musique]